and uh
just catching this issue areas and so on
so we got into a correspondence and so
this went on for some months and uh
i also criticized the fact that he was
only
unifying gravity with electromagnetism
and that that we knew about the nuclear
force
i mean there was already nuclear what we
call nuclear physics
so how can you leave that out okay and
he responded to that
so
then
we have we had a friend my father
had a friend who was a
chemist
and uh living he called me an american
and uh
he got to hear about me and uh
then he
somehow got neal's boy at the point it
should
come to hear about me
and i was invited to the boar institute
and i was interviewed by niels paul for
two hours he criticized einstein because
people
felt einstein was wasting his time
moore criticized einstein yeah and said
that uh
albert was wasting his time and
he he said
i was like an alchemist
trying to turn lead into cold and
so on and so on i just sat there
famous nobel prize winner
thinks another famous nobel prize winner
is wasting his time
okay
i didn't think einstein was wasting his
time
he was doing unified theory
before it ever became popular
at all okay
and uh he was actually ignored at the
institute
by physicists
because
all of his work was just wasting time
so
uh support
so i was a british citizen you see
because i never became a danish citizen
because
i was born in copenhagen but i took my
father's citizenship
so
paul got in touch with uh
the consulate but he's consciously in
copenhagen
uh who got in touch with
department of scientific industrial
association
in london
and they invited me to london
and
so i went there
but
they arranged me for me to be
interviewed by professors
to see whether i was
the real article or
some
figment not somebody's imagination
including my own
and uh
i was interviewed by
william mcrae professor in london
university
and uh
then i was sent to
william bonner who professor liverpool
university who was working on united
states unified field theory he was one
of the people who criticized einstein's
theory for the fact that you couldn't
get the equation of motion for a charged
particle from the theory
and also that maxwell's equation it
didn't look like maxwell's equations as
they should
so
so then i was
sent to to dublin
to h201 study
in dublin
and i've been showing you the famous are
insuring one of the founders of calling
me kelly's the shorting equation i was
director of the institute
so i went there and i went up and he was
interviewed by showing a saddle on his
bed with the whole cap on his head
and small bedroom
and uh he had my papers
which uh i sent a height today
and uh
science i sent it to him no i
had copies and i
had just
given them to bohr and
at the
palm of
uh that i was invited to in london and
so on people
and they sent it to schwelinger
so then he got angry and said why are
you using
albert's methods to do this theory
because schroeding was working on the
non-symmetric theory he published
several papers
i was in the in the um
i've
proceeded the royal irish academy
uh
which published papers on
greek philosophy and all sorts of issues
and
there was a dispute between einstein and
schweininger it turned out
because
showing up
was interviewed by newspapers
because of his uh publication for
unified field theory
and uh claimed that he had solved the
problem
but wasn't happy about this because he
had solved the problem
so they had this personal dispute
and paulie had to intervene because they
got it caught rather
poor albert threatened to show sharing
it oh yeah
anyway so
uh apparently damned things out of kang
paulie
famous
physicist
uh nobel prize winner and um
anyway so this was the atmosphere
i was interviewed
in and uh
so schwein had his way of deriving
the non-symmetric theory and einstein
had his
way doing it then
so training was anxious i wasn't using
heroin schrodinger's away okay why are
you not using my weight
i i said i i i will do that in future
and uh i had to be diplomatic
anyway so back to london
so the next thing is the schrodinger
sent a letter
to the
people in london this department of
scientific
research in london
and uh
the latter argumentation must have been
something
because uh the next thing is i'm sent to
transit college cambridge
to be interviewed by dennis sharma
who was a
student of paul d iraq
and
he was a don fellow of trinity college
and he was always
a lecturer at the time at cambridge
university
and uh
so
i was interviewed by
sharma in his rooms at trinity
and after about 20 minutes she said come
with me
so we walk across
the trinity great court and lawns
only a dawn can walk on the lawns but i
was with him i couldn't eat him
and otherwise you to walk on the gravel
path
and uh taken to the border's office the
trinity and
dennis said this
gentleman john moffett has to be
matriculated as a phd student at the
and this is without an undergraduate
degree nor master so they looked into
this person he said but he doesn't have
any degree
it doesn't matter doesn't matter no okay
so we're meticulating him
and
yes okay
all right so that
so
i was given the
supervisor
uh professor of supervisor fred hoyle
and uh i went to see him at st george
college
in his rooms
and he said well you don't have an
undergraduate degree
no
well maybe you should think about taking
the tripod exams these are the famous
exams antichrist exams like cambridge
and something called the mathematics
tripos
first part and second part and so on
and uh
well i
i was rather precocious and
somewhat arrogant i should say as a
young man i fell in like so i said well
uh
professor ohio is just
this is just going to waste my time
because i know all this okay
so he he looked at me dubiously he went
through
the tripods himself he said in his
biography carl's biography
he
had problems with that
getting through and it was brilliant of
course but
they were very hard exams
and
so he's probably thought well if i
entered two of his voices
this person
with those
20 20 21 year old
you know
so i can understand his attitude
so i decided that something should be
done about this
so i wrote three papers okay within two
or three months
and uh
submitted to the proceeds of cambridge
philosophical society
and the first paper was
very mathematical as a generalization of
romanian geometry
and
the other two were my first modified
gravity theory
and uh long papers
the
paper on the um i was trying to unify
gravity and
electromagnetism in my own way okay so i
invented this
way
no showing a new heinz this is a
different way of doing it
and so
they accepted them
three papers
so i mean
cambridge proceedings as an ancient
history i mean famous mathematicians and
my officers were published there
schrodinger published papers there
they called a mechanic
so i went back to
fred hoyle
and uh
i gave him the papers when he sat and
looked at them
and he said well
forget about the tripods exam just
continue with what you took me
that was it